good morning Jay what's going on there
buddy
now is this going to be an interview
where you tell me what you can tell me
or what you can't tell me I can't talk
about this give me a kid give me a
morsel
you've got no no man you got a tune into
Fox Sports Radio tied are you kidding me
well we'll tell people to do that but if
you've got to give us a tidbit where the
people are going to go all right I got
to go out of my way I'm going to make
sure that I am listening to Jay and
Chris Spielman and Joel clad so give me
some last couple years I've had look I
don't tip on Twitter because I don't
work for Twitter I work for Fox but
we've been able to predict pretty well
most of the picks the last couple years
a couple picks out just because here's
the thing right I don't do a mock draft
because I'm not going to have a team
tell me hey this we're going to do but
you can't tell anybody that it's so that
I'm not gonna lie to the fans it doesn't
make any sense so I think as a result of
that though event teams they definitely
will call inquire say look if we're
looking at this guy what are you hearing
where do we have to move to we have to
appear can we get out of there is this
real is it not real so you're for me I
love it it's you know it's our version
our own little intelligence community
all right but who is who is everybody
curious about either what player what
team who's everybody curious about I
mean everybody serious about
quarterbacks and people all over the
place on the quarterbacks ears you know
this is kind of a different draft and in
most dress you this deepest position is
tied in believe it or not and it's
father defense it's ever been the last
two decades but that's obviously not
flashy nobody says oh my gosh this guy
didn't change everything for me
yeah the thing that always gets me is
that they still go on well this guy all
those projections he has a size speed
high all this stuff but it's totally
different when you come in this level
these Scouts these coaches I think that
they don't analyze enough based on all
right this guy now has 24 hours a day
what's he going to do is it they go off
of
this is what he did when he was able to
work his craft three hours a day and man
if he works harder with us we can really
mold him but in my opinion they don't
put enough effort into whether or not
that guy's going to really outwork the
world on the next level do you think the
Browns are locked in and who they're
going to take it number one I think that
took at look I do think they love
Garrett I do think they liked
quarterback I think he's trying to
figure out what they do there they're
trying to sell it as best they can
the quarterbacks also like for me if I
have to go with somebody I love Watson
because you know he's gonna work his
butt off and people say well he has
accuracy issues Matt's college half
these guys don't run the right routes
anyway he said oh so foot you know the
guy always done is one you know he's
going to work it kind of has that
Russell Wilson voice just can outwork
the world you know it scares me whenever
you have somebody who they say well he
started one year or he is you know
didn't have the greatest record he
couldn't beat out this person but man
he's so athletic that tell me tell me
about that is that sound Brady right
that's where again these guys kind of
get it wrong look at Tom Thomas just I
worked the world look at Drew Brees yeah
I works the world and you have all these
other guys come there with all these
great athletic skills and they don't pan
out in this next level because they just
don't get it but that happened with
Peyton Manning and Ryan Leaf leave had
as much if not more talent than Payton
but Peyton was going to outwork Ryan
Leaf and that was you know one of the
knocks on Ryan was he felt entitled and
he wasn't going to work hard yeah and
obviously I know you guys headline I
think yesterday and the work he's doing
with us or MVP which is unbelievable and
that's why you know we've always kind of
had this little saying in his work we do
with our veterans and uh and our X
players like why you don't you know Ryan
trying to take his own life right and
thank God he didn't because if he did he
never would have been able to help out
all these still thousands are hopefully
eventually millions of people he could
help out you just never know what lies
around next Tuesday he's Jay Glazer at
fun I know I know I'm getting off on a
little tangent here with Ryan but Drive
really appreciative that you guys have
had him on and let him tell that story
if it panned out the way everybody
thought it would and he was this great
player he
wouldn't be saving lives like years
right now Jay Glazer Fox NFL insider for
us Fox Sports Radio tonight at 8:00
Eastern joel clad and Chris Spielman
joining Jays he can tell you who's going
to go do you have any problem telling
people who's going to be picked before
they're picked know I usually on the
radio I'll tell you five picks out and
then I'll tell you this is actually with
their borders this is where they're
looking you know do as good a job that I
can is predict it and make it kind of
add to the subterfuge as much as
possible last year the crazy thing that
happened obviously is Tunsil as around
everybody's on the clock they're calling
everybody they possibly can I'm sure I'm
not just the only insider teams are
calling on what do you know about this
gas mask I'm like I don't know it's a
free gas mask upon - Matt do you want to
me I don't know you know I send it but
here's the thing and it's going that
same thing with Connolly if they don't
have every piece of information on the
kids they're going to pull off they want
as much information as they possibly
have and a guy like ton so last year I
mean yeah was it bad luck yeah but you
know it's just goes to show you how
scare it off they get when they don't
have every single piece of information
on somebody you know and this year
you're just trying to get as many you're
trying to get as few question marks to
get as you can right now guys like you
know obviously Derek Solomon Thomas
people say he's the surest thing in the
draft
you know safety people think that he's
going to come and immediately change the
dynamic of your locker room I still look
at you if you got a guy like fournette
he will completely change the culture of
your offense and we talked about guys a
lot work the world for me McCaffrey is a
no-brainer absolutely no-brainer if you
can't do something he'll end up working
hard enough to figure out how to do it
would you take him over for nin times
what kind of offense I run
if I'm running off central I just want
to pound the rock thirty times a game
like the Vikings have with agent
Peterson a global tour net and so I'm
kind of trying to spread things out and
be really unique and use them in all
different ways obviously I can go look
for Caffrey but it really just depends
what kind of offense you run I don't
think you go wrong with either guy I
think so that's one of these guys don't
come along come along too often so I
just think naturally because he's going
to punish you he will
nealy change the face of your office
you'll wear people out on the other side
of the ball and it's like he's just
going to keep throwing you know straight
straight power shots and power shots and
power shots and power shot until he
starts breaking you down then you can
start hitting that defense all over the
field by the way speaking of power shots
here sell me on Conor McGregor actually
beating Floyd Mayweather if it happens
just the format of this boxing that's I
say look he is fighting Floyd in Floyd
sport it's two totally different sports
it's a limited it's a completely
completely limited art but oh I could
say is what's behind Conor's rib cage
he's different he you know anytime you
that dude wills himself to do stuff that
the rest of us can't and do I give a
puncher's chance of course I give him a
puncher's chance it goes kind of the
both counter punches but he's fighting
in Floyd sport he's not fighting Conor
sport that's like when Jarryd Hayne was
the best rugby player in the world
Australian rules football player in the
world came over in the NFL it barely
made the 49ers but if you took somebody
over here from the NFL and put him over
and you know Aussie Rules Football this
thing the same would probably happen I'd
be interested in the fight I think Conor
has nothing to lose I think a zero to
lose the thing about this fight here - I
mean Floyd cites guys who he kind of
knows he's going to beat I think what
makes you the greatest fighter of all
time is not none to see the record you
go find guys who can beat you and then
if they do you figure out a way to come
back and beat them that's what the I
leave the role did but what about here's
my idea I give Floyd six rounds to knock
out Conor McGregor then after that we go
MMA I like it I have a three rounds I
like that I like that too but Floyd's
not going to knock him out I don't think
so yeah I don't know I mean look just
what floor does oh you know best record
of all time but he doesn't know anything
alone he'll keep but he should but it's
12 rounds is completely different he
should give it everything he has like
this is his sport he says he's the
greatest of all time at that sport he
should not Connor out it's the bottom
line but you know it's a different sport
that Connors moving into
Matt Connor so smart he definitely has
power in both hands do I give him a
puncher's chance yeah but he has nothing
to lose if Floyd beat Sam in boxing yeah
well he was supposed to lose Annie gets
100 million right leave the audience
with this the one player you think
changes the first round of the draft the
one player I think changes the first
round of draft is true Biscay I think he
I think he changed it because there's so
much movement there's gonna end up also
being a look everybody so split on these
quarterbacks the other day I talked to
one coach who absolutely couldn't stand
Kaiser couldn't stand them at the owners
meeting and then I talked to him the
other day and I said you still haven't
lifted and this guy had my home's above
everybody where most don't I said you
still haven't Stanley says no I love
cars and I said me you love Kaiser a
month ago you couldn't stand him he said
well that's before I worked on four
things with his footwork and I talked to
him two weeks later and he had picked it
up I'm are you kidding me well you know
and I'll tell you this two teams right
now as we speak
Kings still don't have their board set
it's amazing
they've got 365 days to do this and they
still are going to mess around with the
board right up until they're on the
clock it's it's unbelievable you can
check out Jay with Joel client Chris
Spielman live streaming their draft
coverage on Fox Sports coming up tonight
Jay thanks for joining us as always
thank you handsome who misses you thank
you buddy that's Jay Glazer he can beat
you up the Dan Patrick show weekday
mornings on audience